now I'd like to introduce then Colin
missing heading up the by the best
indicator group at the Institute of
Pathology London very grateful he made
the trip over to here they'll tell us
about the work at the Institute as well
as some work is involved in with the Red
List and ICM so thanks a lot then and
good afternoon everyone and so the title
of my talk is tracking global
biodiversity change in space and time
and this is me actually doing that in
the flesh I'm going to talk about a lot
of sort of global aggregations of
datasets much like a couple of our
previous speakers has but this is me
actually doing it in the field as well
so I'm trying to maintain a little bit
of that as well so biodiversity change
and conservation decision making is sort
of a broad concept of what I want to
talk about I'm going to try and address
three main questions firstly how should
we track the fate of species and
populations I'll talk to you about a
couple of ways in which we've been doing
that secondly how can we predict their
change in a way that's that is most
useful we've spent the past six or seven
years developing indicators for the
convention on biological diversity but
how can we how can we adapt those and
use them into the future and thirdly
conservation funding is very limited so
how do we best prioritize its use and so
this is the sort of background for
Biological Diversity the conservation
biological diversity over the last
decade or so and the convention that
most nations in the world a signed up to
signatories to to to this agreed in a
2002 to this 2010 target and that was to
reduce their impact on biodiversity and
to do that arranged different scales
from the global to local level these are
the measures that were put forward to
address whether or not that target had
been met on this side you have measures
of state and so the aspects of
biodiversity that we're somewhat
concerned about in the middle pressures
on biodiversity and all of which are
going up
here are responses things like protected
areas biodiversity aid and here the
benefits that humans derive in some way
from biodiversity and in every way that
we manage that measured that the 2010
target was not met those targets were
sort of shaped into what become known as
the IT targets many of which over 2020
and they've been subdivided into 20 sub
targets addressing much much the same in
general terms but but but more more
focused if you like addressing
underlying causes of biodiversity loss
reducing direct pressures on
biodiversity and so forth and so two
measures that we used used to measure
biodiversity the first of which is the
ICN red list and red listings been going
on for 50-plus years the organization
that I work for geological society of
london has been involved in that since
the outset and one of our former
directors Georgina maces really the
architect of the type of criteria the
tools that you use to make these
decisions over time I'm going to assume
that most people of heard of these but
very quickly there are quantitative
criteria by which species can be put
into these categories from sort of safe
as houses to over the edge and every
grade in between that at the bottom here
data deficient species those the way we
don't have sufficient information to put
them into those categories and there's
been a large body of scientists that
have worked over over time to produce
assessments of individual species of
groups of species is the status of
mammals and it gives you information
like twenty-five percent of mammals are
threatened with extinction and we can
see how that varies we can see how that
differs between systems we can see where
those species are and representation on
the species on the red Lister's been
growing rather quickly over recent
decades but really how good is it if
we're trying to use this information to
answer questions about biodiversity in
general how good is it and the answer
that we sort of decided on in
and about two thousand five was that it
actually wasn't very good in red hair in
the bars of sort of these very broad
groups of animals and plants so the
species that are assessed versus in the
blank those that that haven't been
assessed and so this we swords a real
problem there are a number of different
ways in which you can tackle this the
process that we decided on was to try
and implement a sample approach to read
listing so here's my analogy this is
biodiversity as with an iceberg much of
it sits below the water and you don't
see it we don't really know what's going
on so these are the non assessed parts
of biodiversity above the water line
we've got those that we know about
principally birds mammals and amphibians
and but if we can coord ound through
that if we can take a sample of the non
assessed as well as the SS then we can
better explain what's happening with
biodiversity and hopefully make better
decisions just say quickly the way in
which you can work out that sample sizes
you can just draw from sampling theory I
hate to mention it at the moment but
this is this is exactly the same as
polling organizations do when predicting
an election we actually come up with
very similar numbers to them in terms of
how many people you have to ask before
you can get the right answer this is a
subsample of the bird date and it shows
you that once you're at a thousand
species assessed at random from that
group you can tell what's going on in
the whole group and so this graph sort
of wraps up what's about five or six
years work and the input of around about
a thousand scientists and but we've
added many more groups to this this sort
of set of species that we can infer
extinction risk about and there's a few
different interesting patterns firstly
we can see and this was a great surprise
to me that of the invertebrate suit
groups that we've assessed and broadly
they show a very similar level of
extinction risk and to the more sort of
well-known groups of birds mammals and
amphibians similar again with plants
much more variation in that extinction
risk so these grey bars here are those
data deficient species I talked a little
bit about and
as you would expect a sort of a larger
number of those in there but putting in
general similar similar levels of threat
one in five to one in four species
threatened with extinction and with that
we can really start to address what's
happening we can start to track the
changes in categories how those species
fair over time so here's a sort of
famous example in the year 2000 the
polar bear was assessed as least concern
in 2007 it was upgraded to a category of
honorable on account of shrinkage in in
its primary habitat if we do that with
lots of groups lots of species across
groups then you can get the change in
category some sort of better to worse so
a couple of things to note on this graph
firstly the rate at which these
different groups are changing so corals
there versus amphibians here and the
second thing to note is their position
on the y-axis so the further down here
you are the more threatened species you
have in that group we could we can also
start to pull together information about
the threatening processes that are
causing those species to fall into those
categories of extinction so this is an
example of what threats and controls of
threats have led to changes in
categories in birds and mammals so in
red you've got deteriorating species in
green you've got improving species
mammals in the solid bars birds in the
hatched bars a couple of kind of
interesting things pop out there most
birds that are improving in status are
doing so because of control in alien
invasive species most birds that are
getting worse that are deteriorating
states in status are doing so because of
agricultural practice so there's a
mismatch there between what's causing
the threats and what we're doing about
those threats and that's all useful
information at a global level one of the
really important think pieces of
information that any red list assist
assessment gives you is a geographic
range map for that species so here's a
the African elephant and the range mount
for those species and there's been a
real kind of mini industry and pulling
these together you can aggregate those
maps over a global surface so here is a
mammal richness map of the world but as
we've introduced those new groups as we
started to understand how they're
distributed we can see that some of the
patterns that they cause are very
different so this map here is of
freshwater crabs and freshwater crayfish
across the globe and you can see to
speech sort of two groups of species in
a very similar ecological nice shredder
communities in particular really
subdividing the globe a couple of other
examples this marine one reef-building
corals here you can see whether we're
the sort of sensors of richness for
those are versus lobsters if we can move
on where they're really rather different
centers and that matters for
conservation planning obviously if
you're going to put resources into an
area you need to know what species are
there and what's important if we look at
congruence between two different
measures so on the left hand side here
of richness and on the right hand side
of threatened richness in a sort of a
matrix and you can see some really low
numbers there is the thing to take away
from this this figure so congruence
across fresh water taxi which are
increasingly higher threat higher levels
of threats than those in other systems
are really rather poor and what that
means is that if we're going to better
design conservation strategies we need
to assess more species and have a much
fuller picture of how biodiversity is
changing so here's just one example the
lower panel are the threatened sorry the
top 5% richest cells of threatened birds
mammals amphibians and on the top same
same measure but for freshwater fish
dragonflies and damselflies just because
they're the three first groups that we
did you can see some startling area
starting large areas in the world where
if you focused your
if you took the information from the top
set you would choose as the areas to
concentrate on if you took your
information from the bottom set you'd
leave them alone so conclusions and for
that sort of particular section coverage
of risk metrics and range data are
continually improving across taxa
congruence across taxa at a global scale
at least a very varied and that makes
the task of conservation planning much
more difficult with enhanced spatial
data section and an better taxonomic
coverage that will allow us to better
design things like protected area
systems and and the marine system really
kind of lags behind some of them were
some of the terrestrial data sets in the
main but there are people that are
working on that so hopefully that'll
pick up in the next few years second
important measure of biodiversity
changes is that change in abundance and
here I'm going to talk about the Living
Planet Index Living Planet Index was a
kind of a state of the environment
report developed by WWF back in 1997 I
think first launched in in 99 or 2000 we
became involved with them in 2006 in
order to try and strengthen the data
behind this data behind this report and
do some new things with it and what we
do is we collect abundance data across
vertebrate populations various different
sources and types of data the majority
of them are from peer-reviewed primary
journal literature but also NGO
literature the grey literature national
parks and protected area networks and so
forth and different measures for
different species we're talking about
all vertebrates here so you can't be
really kind of dogmatic about the way in
which data are collected so we can get
things like total population estimates
obviously the best thing we can get
density measures biomass estimates
things that relate to correlate with
abundance number of nests for marine
Turtles and then we have a number of
different criteria against any any given
publication
and it has to be traceable there has to
be measured over time to the same method
we have to know where that was done and
then who did it and so forth so few
examples of the types of data that you
might collect so this species southern
right whale from Indian Ocean and
showing a gradual increase in population
number wandering albatross from Bird
Island South Georgia showing a slow
steady decline and the loggerhead turtle
showing a population crash so the day
sets made up of just a almost two
thousand seven hundred species now
roughly equally balanced across
temperate and tropical zones and that
amounts to some 9,000 populations I
think we have about 13,000 in the data
set as a whole now 9,000 of which he
used to calculate the index it's all
going online and very scene and and what
that shows us and sorry it's a bit more
about the data set this is the
distribution of all those abundance time
series data across the globe so you know
some areas where we're good some areas
where we'd like to be better and if you
aggregate those data up what they show
you is that over a 35 year time period
we've lost around about a thirty percent
on average of thirty percent of the
abundance of wild vertebrate fauna and
that's a lot worse in tropical systems
than it is in temperate systems largely
because temperate systems have probably
gone through those changes rather
earlier and to set that against a sort
of the back trouble over that same time
period human population and has
practically doubled and so that's sort
of the output of the report the kind of
the broad headlines and WWF is superb
getting that message out and that report
is produced in 13 different languages
and the print run is in the tens of
thousands the downloads are in the
hundreds of thousands as well as
improving that data set we've been
trying to focus it on new things as well
so here's just one example in the Arctic
so looking down on the top of the globe
here these are the
abundance datasets that we've managed to
callate for that region and if you do
the same things you aggregate those data
up you get different patterns if you
start to pull those patterns apart you
can start to discern what's happening in
different regions so here high arctic
species over that time period of shown
about a twenty percent decline in
comparison to low arctic species which
is because of the geography of this area
of primary primarily marine species
where control of hunting has led to
increase in size over all aggregated
abundance trends are actually very
positive up to a fifty percent increase
over that same time period and in the
subarctic sort of moving along if you
like on a on a steady steady state since
about the seventies and then what we've
looked to do is to try and try and look
at whether we can predict why those
changes have happened in particular in a
spatial context and what land use
changes have gone on what biology can
explain those changes can we pull out
some some sort of broad broad measures
of to describe what's going on and and
and the short answer is it's really it's
we it's really quite difficult and we've
been unsuccessful in really pinning down
exactly what's going on so this map here
shows you the distribution of those
abundance time series again and in the
sort of the hotter colors those time
series little declining quite rapidly in
the cool colors those that are
increasing and we looked at we evaluated
a range of different sort of spatial
measures of change temperature range
anthropogenic land cover natural land
cover change protection human population
density all of those things we were only
able to explain about ten to fifteen
percent of the variance in those data
sets and this is a relatively recent
piece of work so we're going on to sort
of trials and new methods and look for
some better explanatory variables for
that sort of pattern but that's that's
where we're really starting to take
these datasets now
and say through our involvement with
those types of biodiversity indicators
we came to realize that they were they
were being used as tools for
embarrassment you could walk up to a set
of policy makers and say look you know
biodiversity is declined by thirty
percent and it happened on your watch
and they say what are you going to what
should we do about it and we didn't have
a good answer so now we're trying to get
into sort of a more predictive framework
in particular to try to inform and
influence policy so the current set of
indicators selected by the CBD are
really poorly targeted at solutions so
we wanted to know can we do better and
what we decided to do is to develop a
framework to test different policy
options and we drew out a couple of case
studies to do that which I'll tell you
about and really this graph explains
what we're trying to do this is this is
your index of change bit abundance or
risk or it might be range size it could
be anything you like and what we'd
really like to be able to do is is give
policymakers these options you know this
is policy option a B and C this is what
we think is going to happen under those
sets of circumstances this sandwich is
going to cost and to do those things and
really start to give people tools to
make decisions with for our first sort
of attempt to this we targeted CBD
strategic goal see which is about
protected areas is the goal by 2020 at
least seventeen percent of terrestrial
and inland water should be under
protection effects seventeen percent of
the globe should be under protected
areas and so politically derived
decision rather than one that's got a
huge amount of scientific basis we took
all our information from African
protected areas this was published by
PhD student of mine Ian Craigie back in
2011 and what it shows is in those
protected areas across Africa a fifty
percent decline in abundance regionally
it shows rather stark differences so
Eastern in particularly western Africa
are faring much much worse than southern
Africa where a greater history of
protection is in place so we took that
population data set which
spatial data set of who are going to
expand protected areas where should that
happen to the for the sort of in a
systematic way for the best benefit of
species we do together estimates of
populations in 41 countries 53 species
of mammals and we in effect grew those
populations forward according to the
regional trends that we had observed in
the recent past we then reassessed every
decade what what those data told us
counselor calculated abundance trans say
the Living Planet Index calculated total
abundance trends we calculated the red
list index as well so really this is
getting a couple of things firstly
what's happening secondly can our
indicators pick up those changes and we
used four different scenarios one was
business as usual just keep young as we
are second expand protected areas to
seventeen percent thirdly make protected
areas effective effective we've seen
that they're not effective and 4-d both
and we made a bunch of assumptions for
brevity I'll forgo those but I'm happy
to talk about them afterwards and this
is what we showed and so this is the red
list index that I showed you earlier on
but just for these African mammals and
protected areas and it shows you that
without protective management protective
area expansion will be a little value
and that shows us really a couple of
things firstly that perhaps our target
is misguided if we believe these results
it shouldn't be about expansion it
should actually be about the things
which enhanced protection and secondly
it shows us that one of our indicates
that leads can pick up those trends so
that's that's a positive thing for that
indicator a little more detail this is
the Living Planet Index and so that that
measure of abundance rather than risk
sharing much the same story certainly
the same trajectories and a couple of
key differences between the indicators
and so I've just pulled out this one
species just to sort of exemplify this
is what happens under one of the
scenarios for the abundance of that
species across those regions so that's
if you can track total abundance which
let's remind ourselves that most
monitoring programs can't that's your
best case data set if you create an
index of those using abundance and you
keep track of the fact that this is
dropped away to nothing or close to
nothing if you use a red list index so
tracking the extinction risk of that
species you get this really
counterintuitive effect whereby down
here the species gets assessed at least
as least concern again because it's in
protected areas fences around them only
in southern Africa it's been extirpated
from the rest of its range but in it in
effect this index forgets a historical
baseline and that's an unintended
consequence and that we didn't realize
when we were in been sort of putting
this indicator together so a couple of
conclusions expansion is futile without
effective management target achievement
can therefore be misleading if we don't
measure the right things both of our
indicators seem to be able to measure
those trends but perhaps there were some
unintended consequences and the main
caveat this is a it was a very simple
sort of proof of concept trend based
response there's a process involved and
that would be a way to develop this in
the future and so finally I want to go a
little bit into prioritizing
conservation under limited resources
just in the last 45 minutes talked about
how we pull together all those different
types of data on risk and abundance but
how do we actually employ those how do
we use those to make conservation
decisions it's been framed as a sort of
a the agony of choice there are many
deserving causes out there where do you
choose to put your conservation but and
there are lots of ideas on how to do
this threatened species restricted range
endemics flagships be flagship species
indicator species those of the economic
value and so forth but an idea that came
really from from from the literature in
the early 90s was this idea that
phylogenetic diversity or evolutionary
history i'll i'll use the terms
interchangeably and really give you
something that those other measures
perhaps don't and what we should really
do it be doing
is conserving evolutionary potential
phylogenetic diversity because that's a
compound metric of lots of different
things that we valuate genotypic
diversity character feature ecological
diversity and so forth so maximizing pd
that only gives you the most of what
you've got but it gives you the most
options for the future say a little
cartoon example of that I made up
phylogeny here's the echidna out our
branch on it saying if you had to choose
which of species a B or C when extinct
you probably wouldn't choose the a kid
in there because that would lose you 56
mears of 56 million years of independent
evolutionary history but rather you
choose one of these species of rodent
which would lose you a few million you
also know that there's another species
which is very like it which is going to
come back in and take its place so
that's that's the concept but that would
never been implemented in a conservation
program really fourth kind of three
fundamental reasons that I can I can see
firstly branching patterns and lengths
of branches is a difficult thing to do
it's really only with the advent of
molecular phylogeny that we've been able
to bring together the tools to be able
to implement this type of approach
secondly it's a little bit nerdy it's
quite difficult to convince the public
that phylogenetic diversity is something
that they should be concerned about and
perhaps that's the reason why it hadn't
been attempted and finally there's been
a lot of investment in alternative
approaches say so really why rock the
boat we decided to anyway and say what
you require here is a super tree giving
you the relationship of all mammals and
that's where we are and combine that
with a measure of urgent sorry use that
to calculate an evolutionary diversity
of distinctiveness phylogenetic
distinctiveness which is it in effect
the length of any branch over the number
of species that subtend it again for
brevity oh I'll breeze through breathe
through some of the methods but one of
the things to deal with this is Polly
soumise where you don't have complete
information about any bro
on a given branch lengths or structure
we had a couple of ways to deal with
that which he can go through we
estimated the variance around that take
your measure of urgency from the red
list so just read those categories as
read because they relate directly to
extinction risk and combine that insert
something that's Mathematica math lab
excuse me mathematically sensible so
each increment in category is doubling
of extinction risk so this just combines
those two measures together but what
this really is although this is a
mathematically sensible way to do it
what we've been effect done is taken two
distributions of a phylogenetic
diversity and and and endangerment and
we've said will you know if we had to
split this up this is the one weird
might like most and then we'd like these
species second and these ones third so
forth so it's so there's an element of
sort of an an arbitrary decision making
about this as well a couple of the
facets of this you get a good broad
distribution of different threat types
if you use this if you use this method
so critically endangered endangered and
vulnerable species all in the top 100 we
can look at how robusta is to change
I'll flick through this one we can look
at how we can look at her assalamu we
can look at how performance changes as
the red list changes so we can compare
genuine changes some non genuine changes
we can look at how red list data how
things move between re categorizations
so data division species can move into
any category threatened species tend to
stay threatened and species can become
unex if you like so we need to
understand that those are okay in our
ranking system we can look at the
impacts of taxonomy whether we split or
lump things whether that affects that
that ranking list that list of species
we think are most important and we can
look at the change in ranks over time so
to wrap this up we we sort of put our
money where our mouth is and when
and having developed this academic
approach win and implemented it you can
go to the website said I sell dog food /
edge it's a very rich website lots of
blogs attaching people to to the
projects in the field we focused on
those species where no conservation
attention was being placed it gives you
your focal species these are these are
some of them for the mammals we have a
sort of a fellowship program within
country scientists we work with them
over a two to three year period too and
they actually implement that the science
and behind this method and in the
science behind the conservation program
and that we're trying to implement we've
expanded out over a number of groups
corals amphibians birds are on the way
and we sold it to the public our press
offices when we told them about the idea
told us just a not bother we were doing
interviews for two weeks solidly when we
launched this in 2007 so it has theirs I
don't know whether it's something about
the UK whether it's something about you
know sort of rooting for the underdog
but it's certainly struck a chord and
there are some signs of success we get a
million I got over a million unique web
site visits on day one and which is now
50,000 50,000 unique visits a month
we've got a community of scientists
involved we funded 50 different
conservation fellows around the world on
two-year schemes and but the real kind
of test of this really will be do the
species improving status and that's
something that any time will tell those
are my acknowledgments a lot of people
have been involved in different aspects
of this work and these are funders and
data partners thank you for your
attention and I'm happy to take any
questions
6l up in a little overtime yourself head
other why didn't you already come up and
get started here but let's grab a couple
of inches of these litter this would be
over there combining the edge species
would be
laxman 0 station dating sites were put
in place in this relationship so that
power of our teenagers another question
that's great because then we can move on
to her out of the world again Ben is
around thanks a lot then